[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So welcome, everyone,
to this Talks at Google event.
We are here with
Beau Lotto, who's
going to be talking about
his new book, "Deviate."
So Beau, he's a world-renowned
neuroscientist, entrepreneur,
and also a two-time
TED Talk speaker.
And in this book "Deviate," he's
drawing from over two decades
of research to reveal
startling truths
about how we perceive
the world and how
our brain perceives the world.
So without further ado, I'm
going to leave it to Beau.
BEAU LOTTO: [LAUGHS]
Hey, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
That's nice.
So thanks for coming.
It's such a lovely day outside.
It's nice to be-- would have
been nice to be out there.
We should do it out there.
So we're going to talk
about perception, right?
And actually, everyone
here in some sense
is dealing with perception.
And the reason is because
perception underpins everything
you think, you
know, you believe,
the clothes you wear, the
people you fall in love with.
Everything begins
with perception.
So to understand
perception is really
to understand not just
how the brain works,
which is what I'm
interested in, of course,
but what it is to be human.
And if you really want to get
people to see differently,
we have to understand
the principles by how we
see in the first place, right?
So a key question to perception
then, which we've all
been thinking about--
in fact, we've
been thinking about
for thousands of years
is, do we see reality?
So how many here
at Google think you
see the world as it really is?
No?
There's always one.
If you're not seeing the
world as it really is,
what are you seeing?
How did you get
here if you're not
seeing the world accurately?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: You're gonna tell us.
BEAU LOTTO: I'm
going to tell you.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
--I think--
[LAUGH]
--but I'm curious.
I mean, I think you all think
you see the world accurately.
Why?
Because I think you all
believe that illusions exist.
So do you believe in illusions?
Yes?
So an illusion by definition
is to see the world differently
from the way it really is.
So if you believe
in illusions, you
think that you actually evolve
to see the world accurately.
Most of the time, it's just
that sometimes you get it wrong.
So what we can do
is do a quick test
to see how good you are at
seeing the world accurately.
So how many bears do you see?
Three-- only three?
Did you see-- oh,
you only saw two?
OK, keep looking around.
Look differently.
Turn your head.
Imagine.
Can you see four?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] five.
BEAU LOTTO: Five, six.
Do I hear six?
It's like an auction.
AUDIENCE: Is there a panda?
BEAU LOTTO: You see a--
yeah, there could be pandas.
It's a bear, right?
There are 11 bears hiding there.
Right?
The point is, the
more differently you
look at something, the
more things reveal.
But that's actually
quite a complex scene,
so we could try something
much simpler, which
is much more natural.
So how many of you can
see the predator that's
about to jump out at you?
And if you haven't seen it
yet, you're dead, right?
Especially here.
[LAUGHTER]
So who thinks they can
save the rest of the room?
Where do you think it is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: Right-- up there?
At the top?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: OK, you're dead.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
OK, let's just add 10%
of the information,
because 90% of the information
your brain uses to see actually
comes from grayscale.
So we'll add 10%
to the information.
And can you find it now?
All right.
For those who maybe shouldn't
be Google, there it is.
OK.
So now we go back, you can see,
it was always staring at you.
It was always there.
And this makes a
really important point
when it comes to vision,
which is only 10%
of the information--
you can come on in--
which is only 10%
of the information
your brain uses to see
actually comes from your eyes.
The other 90% comes from
other parts of your brain.
So your eyes are
almost pointless when
it comes to vision, right?
It's like the keyboard
is to a computer.
It's how you get the
stuff in, but it's
very little to that
you actually see.
But again, this is still
a fairly complex scene.
So let's try something
even simpler,
which is just lightness.
Surely people at Google
can see the world
accurately in terms of
light intensity, right?
Even jellyfish
can see lightness,
and they don't even
have a brain, right?
So surely, you can see
the world accurately.
And if that's true, then
things that are the same
should always look the same,
and things that are different
should always look different.
And these two circles
are physically the same.
And do they look the same?
Yeah?
Right?
So thank goodness, at
least at this level,
you can see the
world accurately.
But what happens if I
don't change those dots,
I just change what
surrounds them?
What happens to your perception?
Do they still look the same?
AUDIENCE: No.
BEAU LOTTO: No.
The one on the left will
probably look lighter
than the one on the right, yes?
And this makes it--
so nothing's actually changing
on those circles, just
your perception of them.
And this is the simplest
illusion that your brain has,
which is called simultaneous
brightness contrast,
and we really don't
know how it works.
But what it demonstrates is
the most basic level of vision,
of perception, which remember,
underpins everything it
is to be you, context
is everything.
Your brain did not actually
evolve to do absolutes.
It evolved to do relationships.
It's not interested unless it's
contextual in contrast, OK?
So much so that as you're
looking at me right now,
your eyes are actually moving.
They're called saccades
and microsaccades.
And you can stop your eyes
from moving by closing one eye,
sticking your finger into the
tear duct, and pushing back--
right?
You can do it at home with your
kids or your friends, right?
And you're basically
pushing your eyeball back
into its socket, and
your eye stops moving.
What happens?
Your eyes open, and your
eyeballs stop moving.
What do you think happened?
You go blind.
Of course, you'll go blind
if you shove your finger
into the back, right?
But by just simply stopping
your eye from moving,
your brain has nothing
interesting to see,
because it's only interested
in change in space and time.
So if you stop change,
your brain goes blind, OK?
So we've known that
context is everything
for a very long time,
but a far deeper question
is not that context is
everything, but why it is.
And to understand why
context is everything
is really to
understand what it is
to be human, but also to
understand how it is we can
help people to see differently.
So instead of telling you,
I'm going to show you.
And this is actually at the
heart of machine vision,
of automatic cars, et cetera.
This is the fundamental
problem that visual systems
evolved to solve.
So hold up your
finger, and see if you
can make your finger the
same size as me by lining up
your finger with me, right?
The right finger, right?
Can you make us the same size?
Yes?
OK.
We're not the same size, right?
This is because--
[LAUGHTER]
--right?
But as far as your eye is
concerned, we are the same.
It's because data that falls
onto your eyes, into your ears,
onto your skin conflates
multiple aspects of the world.
In this case, size
and distance, right?
But the only access
we have to the world
is the data that
your senses detect.
But the data that
your senses detect
is completely
meaningless, right?
Which makes data itself-- so
who's working on big data?
We're at Google, right?
Data is pointless, right?
It is literally pointless
in and of itself
because it doesn't tell
your brain what to do.
It doesn't come
with instructions.
It conflates multiple
aspects of the world.
And this is true at the
most fundamental level
of perception.
It could be a loud
thing far away
or a quiet object up close, or a
bright object under dark light,
or a dark object under
bright light, right?
These different
aspects of the world
can give rise to
identical pieces of data,
but we have no
access to that world.
So how does your brain deal
with the fundamental challenge
that it is to survive,
which is uncertainty?
This is the problem that
every single brain--
in fact, every
single neural net--
is adapted to deal with, which
is uncertainty, ambiguity.
So what's the other
piece of information
your brain has to see, except
for the data and the moment?
What else does it
have access to?
AUDIENCE: Memory.
BEAU LOTTO: Memory.
Experience.
So the functional
structure of your brain
is literally a
physical manifestation
of its past interactions
with the world.
And not a passive interaction,
but a physical interaction.
Your brain makes meaning
by physically interacting
with the sources of
the meaningless data,
and it makes meaning from it.
That's how your brain
then shapes itself.
It's not a passive
receiving of information,
which is why your brain
actually evolved to continually
redefine normality, right?
And you see everything
relative to that
continually changing normal.
So I want to show you how
quickly your brain can redefine
normality by first noticing
that those two desert scenes are
basically the same, yes?
One is just a flipping
of the other one.
In terms of color, the same.
I want you to stare at the dot
between the red and the green.
Don't look anywhere else.
OK, we're going to do
a bit of a magic trick,
but it's going to happen
inside your head, OK?
So as you're
staring at that dot,
your brain is
redefining normality.
It's learning that the left
side of its visual field
is under green light and
the right side is under red.
That's becoming its
new reality, right?
You're also getting very sleepy.
Keep looking at that dot.
Don't look anywhere else.
When I tell you to,
I want you to look
at the dot between the
desert scenes, but not yet.
OK, five, four, three, two, one.
Do they still look the same?
AUDIENCE: No.
BEAU LOTTO: No?
The one on the left should look
reddish, the one on the right
should look greenish.
Yes?
And now as you look
around, your brain
will continue to
redefine normality again.
Yes?
So that's how quick your
brain redefines normality
at the most basic
level of lightness.
So when you open your
eyes, what do you see?
You can't see the
world as it really
is because your brain is
forever separate from that.
You can't see the
data, or it would
be pointless to see the data,
because it could mean anything.
So instead, what you
see is a meaning that
was useful to see in the past.
You see what we call the
empirical significance
of information.
You see the behavioral value
of the data, not the data.
That is literally what
you're seeing, right?
So the reason why
your brain adapts
is because what was once
useful may no longer be useful.
So your brain is continually
redefining normality
and seeing things relative
to that changing normal.
So to give you a sense of
what I mean by seeing meaning,
we'll do it in the
context of language,
so we'll pretend like
we're in a classroom, OK?
So in the next few slides, I
want you to read what you see.
We'll do it all together, OK?
Ready, one, two, three.
AUDIENCE: Can you read this?
BEAU LOTTO: Good.
One, two, three.
AUDIENCE: You are
not reading this.
[LAUGH]
BEAU LOTTO: One, two, three.
AUDIENCE: [GIBBERISH]
[LAUGHTER]
BEAU LOTTO: Right?
OK, one, two, three.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: What are
you reading, right?
Remember the instructions.
I said, read what you see.
There are no words there.
You all failed, right?
That literally says,
w at ar ou rea in ?
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
There's no law of
physics that tells you
how to put an H between that
W and A. Why do you do so?
Because your brain has
encoded the statistics
of co-ocurring letters in the
English and other languages.
So when you're presented with
a completely arbitrary context
of W space AT, you
put an H there,
because it was useful
to do so in the past.
But there's no inherent
value in this letter string.
It's completely arbitrary.
It doesn't exist without us.
And also notice, none of you
read, what are you dreaming?
Because I had you reading.
That was your recent history.
So you interpreted this in
terms of your recent history.
So you read, what are
you reading, right?
And this is true at the most
basic level of perception.
So if you think
back to lightness,
which again, is our
simplest perception,
you'll see a dark brown tile at
the top and a light orange tile
at the side, yes?
That is your
perception of reality.
You will bet your life that
they are different, yes?
When in fact, they're
exactly the same.
Nothing is changing
on the screen
at all except the
meaning of the data.
You're seeing not
the information,
but the meaning
of the information
based on your history.
And not just your history.
The history of your
culture and the history
of your evolutionary ancestors.
Most of your life happened
without you there.
We come into the world with all
kinds of perceptual meanings.
What's true for color
is also true for form.
So these two tables
are the same, agreed?
No?
[LAUGHTER]
What's wrong?
No.
The red table is simply the
green table on its side.
They have the exact
same dimensions.
The only thing that varies
are the angles at the corner.
Again, you're seeing the meaning
of the data, not the data.
It would be pointless
to see the data.
The data is they have the
exact same dimensions.
But behaviorally,
that wouldn't have
been useful in the
past, given the context.
And what's true
for color and form
is also true for more
complex perceptions,
like the combination
of light and sound.
So when I play
this video, this is
something we worked on
for BBC many years ago,
and it's called
the McGurk effect.
And so when I play the sound,
you'll notice he says--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Fah.
BEAU LOTTO: Fah, as in F. Yes?
- Fah, fah.
[END PLAYBACK]
Of course, right?
And on the right, you'll
notice he says bah,
as an a B, bah, right?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Bah, bah, bah, bah.
[END PLAYBACK]
BEAU LOTTO: Yes?
Simple.
So when I play
them both together,
you have fah on the left
and bah on the right.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Fah, bah, fah.
Bah, fah, bah.
BEAU LOTTO: Great.
Now close your eyes.
- Fah, bah, fah.
BEAU LOTTO: How many
sounds do you hear?
- Fah, bah, fah.
[END PLAYBACK]
BEAU LOTTO: There's one sound.
There's only ever one sound.
If you see his lips make the
shape of an F, you hear a fah.
If his lips the shape of a
B, you hear a bah, right?
And notice, the sound's not
even coming from the screen.
It's coming from the
speakers up there, right?
Nothing's changing.
You're seeing the meaning of
the data based on the context,
right?
We could watch this all day.
[LAUGHTER]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Fah, bah.
[END PLAYBACK]
BEAU LOTTO: [INAUDIBLE], right?
Which means that
life is actually
really quite simple, right?
Very fundamental, very basic.
At any point in time,
your brain is only ever
making one choice, one
decision at any moment in time,
which is, do I go
towards something
or do I go away from
something, right?
And whether you go
towards or away,
the perceptions that you
have, the behaviors you make
are simply a reflex
grounded in your history.
You have no free will
in what you're doing,
perceiving right now.
It's just like when the doctor
hits your patellar tendon,
and your leg goes out, right?
It is a reflex,
and that reflex is
grounded based on what
was useful to do perceived
in the past.
OK?
So whether you go
towards or away
is determined by your
history, your culture history,
your evolutionary history.
You have very little
control in the moment
of what you're going to do.
So what you perceive, the
history that you perceive
is not what the thing
turned out to be.
It's not the data.
It's simply what you
perceived before.
So what you perceive
now, what you
do now is what you did
before, the history
of your past perceptions, OK?
So I'm going to show
you how powerful this
is in the context of sound.
I'm going to get you to hear
something that originally
doesn't even exist,
and it's going
to be simply because of your
history of having perceived it.
So first of all--
[GIBBERISH MUSIC]
--there are no
words in this, yes?
[GIBBERISH MUSIC]
It's nothing interesting.
Do you hear something?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: [INAUDIBLE]
BEAU LOTTO: Let's find out.
Let's try this, right?
Read along and listen.
[GIBBERISH MUSIC]
Can you hear it?
Yeah?
Are you getting
better hearing it?
Notice you're getting
better at hearing something
that doesn't actually exist.
You're becoming
delusional, right?
Which is actually the--
[LAUGHTER]
--right?
Which is the power and
the beautiful thing
about the human brain, right?
We can imagine.
But the point here is that
you're perceiving something
based on your history
of perceiving it.
And what is this sound?
It's simply this
played backwards.
[MUSIC- QUEEN, "ANOTHER ONE
BITES THE DUST"]
Right?
Which means that you're
like this little guy
in a space of possibility.
Your brain can
never do big jumps.
I can't get from
here to the door
without passing through
the space between, right?
At any moment in time, you're
going to make a choice,
and your choice is to go to
the next most likely possible
based on your history
of experience.
And we could represent
this mathematically
in terms of a space of
possibility, a search space.
And you can't just teleport
yourself around the space.
You can only ever
make small steps.
And you're going to make
small steps determined
by the dimensionality, the
structure of the space.
So you're going to the
next most likely possible.
And what determines the
structure of the space
are your assumptions.
That's what
experience gives you.
It gives you your
assumptions and biases.
Which means that
everything you do
is grounded in
those assumptions.
It's not that sometimes
you have an assumption.
You always have an assumption.
So it's as if your
brain is given
this data, this completely
meaningless, arbitrary data,
which is just energy
from the world,
and it constructs
these perceptions,
and it projects them
out into the world.
So if a tree falls in the world
and no one's there to hear it,
does it make a sound?
The answer is no.
It creates energy, but
it doesn't make a sound,
because the sound is a
construct of your brain.
In the same way that
this screen is not blue,
these chairs are
not white, right?
That is not red, your shirt.
It couldn't be closer to you.
It's actually literally inside
your head, projected outward.
We color objects.
We color the world.
We are the source of
those perceptions.
We color the world.
Color is not a function
of the world itself.
And we project these meanings
even into more complex ideas.
So here's an example.
This was a video
made in the 19--
mid-1940s.
And of course, there's nothing
meaningful about these two
triangles in this circle
until we put them in motion.
And immediately, we start
projecting a meaning
onto these completely
arbitrary objects.
We start hating one,
fearful for another.
This is basically a
horror film, right?
Watch.
Look at that.
You're scared for the circle.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
The meanings don't
exist on the screen.
Pain is a perfect example.
There's nothing
painful in the world.
Painful pain is a
useful perception
about the world that exists
inside your head, right?
And so what's true for color,
what's true for objects,
is actually true
for other people.
You have no access to the
spectral qualities of surfaces,
but nor do you have access
to inside someone's head.
You have no access to
another person's thoughts.
People are just the sources
of meaningless data, right?
You are the source of
your own meaningless data.
You then project a
meaning onto them.
Every personality you
perceive is actually inside
you projected outward.
You have no way of
determining whether or not
your perceptions are
actually accurate.
When you connect
with someone, it's
because your perceived
meaning of them
happens to coincide
with their perceived
meaning of themselves.
Right?
We color other people.
You're a complete group within.
So I'm going to show you
how powerful this is, just
simply in terms of a
funny American football
situation where, notice how
the behavior of the quarterback
completely changes his perceived
meaning by the defense.
OK?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CHANTING]
- Go!
Go!
[CHEERING]
[END PLAYBACK]
BEAU LOTTO: You
can do that once.
[LAUGH]
Right?
So when it comes to
perception, which
underpins everything
it is to be human,
we are just like this frog.
And I don't mean we're
metaphorically like this frog.
I mean we're literally
like this frog.
So this is virtual
reality for a frog, right?
Right?
It's getting a
stimulus, and it's
generating behavior that
was useful in the past, just
like us.
It's like a "Black Mirror"
episode for a frog.
[LAUGH]
And he's doing quite well.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Ah!
Ah.
[END PLAYBACK]
BEAU LOTTO: Right.
And when things don't
go quite our way,
we also get a bit
annoyed, right?
Now you're probably thinking,
I'm not like a frog.
I've got free will.
They might be frogs.
I'm not a frog.
I have free will.
So we're going to
test your free will.
We're going to see if I can read
everybody's mind in this room,
right all at the same
time by predicting
what name you're
going to give two
completely arbitrary shapes.
These are meaningless shapes.
They're not circles,
diamonds, or squares.
They have no name, agreed?
Yes?
OK.
I'm going to give you two
completely arbitrary sounds.
One is kiki and the
other is booboo, right?
They also don't mean anything.
Now you're independent,
freethinking people.
Tell me, which of these shapes,
which has no name, is kiki,
and which of these
shapes is booboo?
Right?
AUDIENCE: Kiki on the left.
BEAU LOTTO: How many
on the right-- yeah,
say booboo's on the right
and kiki's on the left, yes?
How many of you want
to say the opposite?
So I read your minds, right?
Why is this happening?
Why do you associate
them this way?
It's the shapes.
What is it about the shapes?
AUDIENCE: Shape of the
letters [INAUDIBLE]
BEAU LOTTO: It could be
the shapes of the letters.
It actually has to do
with the sharpness, right?
It has to do with actually
your perception of pain.
Your brain has an
overrepresentation
of roundness and
sharpness because it was
behaviorally useful to do so.
And kiki and booboo are
sharp and rounded sounds.
So if I give you the word
love and hate, how many of you
say the one on the right is
love and the one on the left
is hate?
Yes?
Depending on the state of
your relationship, right?
Right?
Because if I give you the word
hate and I prick your finger,
I activate the same
part of your brain,
because hate is
actually painful.
It's the behavioral
significance of the word
that your brain is
encoding, right?
And it's behavioral [INAUDIBLE]
of those sharp corners, which
is pain.
OK?
This is the basis of metaphor.
You're mapping meanings.
You're not mapping data.
So if this is true, if
everything that I see
is grounded in my history,
and what that history gives
me are assumptions, and
those assumptions are
essential for my survival--
every time I take a step,
my brain has all
kinds of assumptions
that the floor is not
going to give way,
my legs aren't
going to give away.
These are essential
for our survival.
But the problem is,
the world changes.
So what was once
useful may no longer
be useful, so we have to
change our assumptions.
And that's the basis for
how we see differently.
Change your assumptions, and
you'll change your perception.
Right?
If your space of possibility is
determined by your assumptions,
if what lies right next
to me is determined
by what I assume to
be true, by changing
what I assume to be
true, I'll change
what lies right next to me, OK?
I'm going to show you how
powerful this is, simply
in the context of
perceived motion.
So as I put this into motion,
you'll probably assume it's
spinning from left
to right, yes?
That's because your brain
has the assumption that it
looks down onto surfaces.
We come into the world
with this assumption,
with this bias,
in the same way we
come into the world
with the assumption
that light comes from above, OK?
We incorporate the laws of
physics into our perception.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: We'll
come to that, OK?
So for most of you, the
most likely perception,
given the assumption, it's
because your brain has
a different assumption,
which you're not aware of,
but I'll make it
explicit in a second.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: But the
explicit assumption
is that you're actually looking
up at the surface, not down.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: It could be.
It could be.
So most of you will assume
that your brain is actually
looking down to that surface.
If you're looking
down at that surface,
then the most likely
perception is left to right.
The possibility that it's
spinning right to left
is actually impossible
given that assumption.
But if I put into
motion, and you
try to play with
your assumption,
challenge your assumption,
imagine looking up
at it instead of
down, it will then
go in the opposite
direction, right?
So sometimes if you
blur your eyes, blink,
you can get it to flip.
So can you get it to go
in the opposite direction,
or do you have it just going
in that same direction?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: Yes.
BEAU LOTTO: Exactly.
Can you get it to flip though?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: Yeah.
But the reason why it's flipping
is-- can you get it to flip?
Who else can get it to flip?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BEAU LOTTO: Yeah?
Blur your eyes and blink
and look around it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: Yeah.
OK.
AUDIENCE: There we go.
BEAU LOTTO: You get it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: OK.
What's happening is
basically, when you assume--
when your brain has the
assumption that you're
looking down onto the surface,
the most likely interpretation
is left to right, right?
Given that assumption.
As soon as you change that
assumption that you're
looking up at it, the most
likely perception is it's
spinning the opposite
direction, from right to left.
What was previously
possible becomes impossible.
You can no longer see it
spinning from left to right
because you've changed
your perception.
And every time you switch your
perception, what your brain is
doing is changing its
assumption of whether it's
looking up or down, because
it has a different meaning
depending on that assumption.
While the stimulus might
be bistable mathematically,
it's not bistable in your head.
It's determined by what
assumptions you're making.
So what was once impossible
becomes possible.
Once possible becomes
the impossible.
All you're doing is
changing your assumptions.
And we're just
talking about motion.
This is what creativity is.
Your brain never does big jumps.
It never brings two things
that are far apart together.
It only ever makes
a small step, right?
But it changes what's next to
it by changing its search space,
by changing the assumptions
that define that search space.
So a quick question, which is,
which direction is it actually
rotating?
How many think left to right?
Right to left?
I don't care.
There's no motion on
the screen at all.
There's literally no motion.
Agreed?
No?
I mean, it's an
animation, right?
You're looking at a
series of still images
that are slightly
different from each other.
Your brain is taking
that small change
and seeing the meaning
of the change, which
we call fine motion.
If I took all those images and
put them in random sequence,
you would simply see a flicker.
So you're seeing the meaning
of the change, not the change.
OK.
So this idea that "creativity
is this chaotic, messy,
serendipitous process"
is predicated on the idea
that the brain puts two things
that are far apart together,
that it actually
jumps, teleports
within its search space.
That's not how
adaptive systems work.
They only ever do small steps.
So if that's true,
then in fact, there's
nothing creative
about creativity.
It's only creative
from the outside.
When you see someone
putting two things that
are far apart together,
it's because for you, they
are far apart together.
You have a different
search space.
For them, they're
making not a simple,
but they're making
a logical next step,
consciously or unconsciously,
to the next most likely
possible based on
their search space,
which is based on
their assumptions.
Because they have
different assumptions,
a different history, they have
a different search space, Right?
And you think, wow.
How did they do that?
How did they bring those two
things that far apart together?
Again, for you, they are.
For them, they're not.
So creativity is this
process of taking small steps
to the next most
likely, changing
your space of possibility by
questioning your assumptions.
OK?
And that's the basis
for how we change
our assumptions, which is all
revolutions begin with a joke.
They begin with a question.
Nothing interesting
begins with knowing.
It begins with not knowing.
It doesn't begin with an answer.
It begins with a question, and
it begins with a good question.
You could be a great
experimentalist, come up
with a great
experimental design.
But if you're asking a
bad question, who cares?
The cash is in a good
question, not necessarily
in the right answer, right?
So if you're actually
wanting to get someone
to shift from A to
B, the first step
is not actually B. The
first step is just to stop.
The first step is to stop
the association that you're
making with that stimulus.
The first step is to go to
not A. If what I'm doing
is I get a stimulus
and I automatically
generate a meaning,
the first step is not
to create a new meaning.
The first step is to not make
that meaning, to go to not A.
And then once you're in
that space of uncertainty,
now you can go in
multiple directions.
So you can control the process
of going to not A, right?
But you can't control
where you go next.
And we'll come to the
importance of ecology
for where you go next after, OK?
But if this is true, if asking
questions, and in particular,
good questions is the
basis of creativity,
why is it so difficult
to ask a good question?
Why is that so hard for us?
I'm going to suggest two
main reasons for this.
There are others, but
these are two main reasons.
And the first one
is that we often
walk through life
thinking we have
an objective view of the world,
that we're rational, right?
That we have no
assumptions and biases.
Or we'll admit that sometimes we
do, it's just that not always.
But the point here
is every time you
make a perception
or a behavior, you
have biases and assumptions.
You can never escape from them.
You can change them,
but you can never
escape from having
assumptions and biases, right?
So here's a game you can play
when you have people around
for dinner, and you can do
it as a thought experiment
right now to demonstrate the
irrationality of who we are.
Imagine you have
a glass of water,
and imagine spitting inside
your glass of water, right?
So do this at home when you
have friends around, right?
Imagine--
[LAUGHTER]
--imagine spitting into
your glass of water, right?
So now imagine drinking it.
Do you get a sense of disgust?
But it's completely
irrational, right?
What was once in your
mouth, you're simply
putting right back in, right?
It's just part of you, right?
But we can't help but generate
this perception of disgust,
even though it's
completely rational.
AUDIENCE: Kids wouldn't
mind to do that.
BEAU LOTTO: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Kids wouldn't
mind to do that.
BEAU LOTTO: No, kids
would be fine with it.
Even if it was
someone else's saliva,
they'd be fine with it, right?
Right?
So everything you do has a bias.
Everything you do has
an assumption, OK?
But the other problem is that
these assumptions are often
hidden to us.
We often have no idea
why we do what we do,
in the same way you didn't
know why you necessarily
named those two shapes
kiki and booboo.
Our assumptions are
often hidden to us,
and here's an example of one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So there's nothing
Barack Obama could do
to prove that he was born here.
- If there was
maybe witnesses that
were in attendance at his birth.
- Like his mother?
Would you listen to his mother?
- No, no, no.
She has motivation to lie.
- So you don't trust Donald
Trump's birth certificate
either?
- Uh, yeah, because
he's been here forever.
- Well, how do you know?
But how do you--
what's your proof?
- Um, well, his parents and--
- But no, they're biased.
I'm talking about,
like, people who could--
- Why would they be biased?
- Well, like, I'm just using
your logic against you.
[END PLAYBACK]
BEAU LOTTO: Right?
[LAUGHTER]
And we laugh, but we're
no different, right?
Everything we do
are assumptions,
and we often don't
know that we're
being guided, our
decisions, our choices
are being guided by
these assumptions that
are almost blind to us, right?
We're blind to them, right?
Hence the power of
diversity of groups.
So diversity of groups have
at least two significances.
First of all, the best person
to reveal your own assumptions
to you is rarely you.
It's usually someone else in
the right kind of environment.
So if you give me
two groups, one
average to lower IQ from
a more diverse background,
versus another group which
has a higher average IQ,
but from the same background,
I want the first group, right?
Because in that group
in the right setting,
they're more likely to
reveal their own assumptions
to each other.
What's more, the search
space of that group
is much more complex.
It's a higher
dimensional search space,
because they have more
diverse assumptions.
And we know from
complex systems theory
that the best solutions
are more likely to exist
in a more complex search space
than in a simpler search space.
A simpler search space is more
adaptable, more evolvable,
but it's actually less likely
to hold the best solution.
So I want the first group.
I discover what my
assumptions are,
and I can occupy within
a more complex search
space in the right environment,
which I'll come to in a moment.
And the kind of search space
and the kind of combination
diversity that we tend to work
with is expert with naive.
And the reason is because
experts are super efficient,
but they're terrible
asking a good question.
But what's ironic is they
can recognize a good question
when asked.
Whereas people who are naive,
they can ask great questions,
but they don't know
they're great questions.
So we find it's a
great combination.
And also the power
of actually stepping
into a space which is
different from what you know.
So you can actually shift
yourself from expert and naive,
and back and forth.
So you can occupy both ways
of being at the same time.
So both in groups,
but also internally.
It is the combination
of expert and naive.
And also, think
about technology.
It's obviously here.
So what defines the
best technology?
One argument is
that it's not what
enables us to do what we
can already do faster,
easier, with less friction.
Those are good technologies.
They're useful.
They're not necessary
transformative.
What are the ones that
are transformative?
I'd suggest they make
the invisible visible.
They enable us to see what
we couldn't see before.
A microscope, a telescope, MRI.
Even a book.
Being able to travel to
a new culture, right?
Because not only does that
reveal our own assumptions
to ourselves.
It enables us to expand the
complexity of our assumptions.
To shift from being the
center of the universe
to then revolving around,
orbiting around the sun,
completely changed
our assumptions
of what it was to be human.
Those are transformative
technologies
that enable us to see what
we couldn't see previously.
Which is why creativity
actually begins with humility.
It begins with not knowing.
So actually, one of
my aims in this talk
is that you know less
at the end than you
think you know now, right?
Because nothing interesting
begins with knowing.
It begins with not knowing.
So the second one, and
the most difficult,
is it might be that you now
accept that everything you do
has a bias and an
assumption, and that you're
going to now try to
reveal what they are
to yourself or through others.
But now you have the next step,
which is to question them.
But we hate not knowing, because
to question an assumption,
especially the assumptions
that define who you are,
puts you into uncertainty.
And we hate uncertainty.
To not be sure that was a
predator, it's too late.
Your brain evolved to
take what is uncertain
and to make it certain.
So when you go down
below in a boat
and you're either moving
relative to the boat,
your eyes are saying,
oh, we're standing still.
But your inner ears
are saying, no, no.
We're moving.
And your brain cannot
deal with that conflict,
which is one of the reasons
why you get seasick.
So you go above deck and
you watch the horizon,
so your eyes and inner ears
are moving in register.
We hate uncertainty,
because dying is easy.
To step into uncertainty
is literally-- to not know
throughout evolution
was to increase
the probability of dying.
Your brain evolved to predict.
The better it's able to
predict, the more likely
it is able to survive.
OK?
And what's more,
the best questions
create the most uncertainty.
So for instance, imagine we
were remodel your biases,
your assumptions as
a network, right?
Which we could do with the
gene regulatory network
or your biases, right?
And in the upper left, those
are your biases that are not
connected to each other, right?
It'd be like a gene
that's encoding
the color of your eyes, OK?
Now if we're to
question that bias
and metaphorically move
it, nothing else changes.
Just that bias.
Now imagine instead
you question a bias,
you move a bias
that's fully connected
to all your other assumptions,
something that maybe
defines what it is to be you.
That would be an
example of, say,
a homeobox gene that determines
segmentation of the body.
If you shift that by--
it's the same amount
of energy, same
amount of movement,
the whole system shifts.
This is what we call
in complex systems
a point of self-criticality.
And we experience this
in nature all the time.
Here's an example.
This snow bank is under a
tremendous amount of tension,
because it's fully connected.
You add a small
amount of weight,
and the whole thing gives way.
So great questions can cause
massive shifts in uncertainty.
And now you're all wondering
whether or not he survived.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BEAU LOTTO: Yeah.
I'm not going to tell
you just yet, right?
Because you are experiencing
uncertainty, right?
That's what it is
being uncertain.
You want to know, right?
We hate not knowing and
sitting with that moment
of not knowing.
And yet, the irony is
that's the only place
you can go if you're ever
going to be creative,
is to step into uncertainty.
And again, to be in uncertainty
creates a tremendous amount
of stress.
That's one of our
biggest sources
of unwellness in our world
is the speed and uncertainty,
right?
It actually decreases
connectivity within the brain,
decreases adaptability,
increases brain cell death.
It actually makes you a more
extreme version of yourself.
If you're a liberal,
you become more liberal.
If you're a conservative,
you become more conservative.
You go to a place
that is familiar.
Almost every
behavior you do, you
do in order to
increase certainty.
You could argue it's
one of the reasons why
Uber was originally successful.
Not because they enabled
you to order a taxi easier.
It's because they told you when
the taxi was going to arrive.
If I put you in San Francisco
on the street corner
and you're trying to catch a
taxi, and after five minutes,
all these are going by,
you're completely stressed,
your cortisol
levels are going up.
And finally, you get a taxi.
Now if instead I sit you
on the same street corner,
and after five
minutes I say, don't
worry, it'll be there
in five minutes, right?
You're using your phone,
your cortisol levels
go down, et cetera.
Right?
It's because of uncertainty.
Which is why in London now, they
put the times on all the bus
stops.
Even though it's going
to be an hour and a half
before the bus gets
there, but knowing it's
going to be an hour and a
half decreases your stress.
And at Terminal 5 in Heathrow,
wonderful, classic example.
You get off the Heathrow
Express, you go into a lift.
There's only one place
for this lift to go,
which is one floor
up to departures.
So you step in, the doors shut,
and now you're trapped, right?
Because there's no button to
tell you to go to floor one.
So the first experience of
this millions and millions
of dollars terminal
was stress, right?
Because of uncertainty.
So what did they do?
They put a little button on the
lift, that when you touched it,
the light went on, and it was
connected to nothing else.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
So you walked in the lift.
You had this sense that, ah.
Thank goodness.
Now it goes-- it was always
going to go up, right?
It was always going to do
exactly what it's doing.
But you had this sense
of certainty now,
of familiarity, right?
We hate uncertainty.
And again, that's the
only place we can go
if we're going to be creative.
So how does the brain
deal with uncertainty?
Because what's more, that
uncertainty and stress
reduces your space
of possibility.
In fact, here's an example
of a space of possibility
reducing to a single dimension.
This happened in Australia.
He's going in to rob a bank.
This actually happened.
He hands the teller
a note, right?
And now suddenly, the
bank gets shut down.
He's trapped.
He's stuck, right?
He's locked in.
But in fact, he's locked within
a completely narrow space
of possibility, one
dimension, because he's
forgotten that doors pull
as well as push, right?
So he was trapped by his
search space, not by the door.
He was caught five
minutes later.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Wait, so it
wasn't actually locked.
BEAU LOTTO: It wasn't locked.
[LAUGHTER]
The door was always open, but he
was pushing against it, right?
Because his search space went
down to a single dimension.
And that's what happens when you
get stressed from uncertainty.
So how can the brain--
but if the only place
we can go to be creative is
to step into uncertainty,
the very place that our brain
evolved to avoid, how is it
that we can actually go there?
What is evolution's
solution to uncertainty?
Because it's essential,
in order to adapt,
that we're able to go there.
So evolution gave us a solution.
So what's the one thing that
you do where you actually
love uncertainty?
It's not that you tolerate it.
You actually seek it.
What's the one
thing that you do?
AUDIENCE: Play games.
BEAU LOTTO: Play.
Play is evolution's
solution to uncertainty.
Is why play evolved, right?
What's more, play is
a way of being, OK?
It's a way-- for
those who study play,
it's not just running
around in a playground.
It is literally a serious way
of being that our brain evolved
to have, OK?
And if we add intention
to play, we get science.
Science is nothing other
than play with intention.
Empiricism is
inherent to the brain.
And how do you define science,
and how do you define play?
So it's not like play.
It literally is play.
When we created an education
program based on this,
it resulted in the youngest
published scientists
in the world, aged
eight to 10 years old,
and the youngest
ever TED speaker.
Because if you add rules
to play, you have a game.
That's an experiment.
But it's rethinking what science
is, which is not a methodology.
That is the craft of
science, but that's not
what defines science.
Science is this way of being,
which celebrates uncertainty.
It encourages diversity.
It's actually how
we create diversity.
The function of science is, in
fact, to increase uncertainty.
Because quality of science
isn't the question you ask.
It's open to possibility.
It's inherently cooperative and
it's intrinsically motivating.
What does it mean to be
intrinsically motivated?
Almost everything you do,
you do for a reward that's
different from what you do.
What is the reward for skiing?
It's skiing.
The reward for play
is play itself.
It's intrinsically motivating.
And that's true
for anything that
is in the process of discovery.
The reward of science,
the reward of discovery
is the discovery itself.
And these are actually
what defines play.
And if we add intention
to play, you have science.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEAU LOTTO: That's true.
So I'm not talking about
the output of science.
But I wouldn't say
science is about truth.
Science is about utility.
Evolution is not about truth.
Evolution is about what's
useful, about predictable,
right?
Even with our mathematics,
we have theorems.
All that theorems are
is making explicit
what your assumptions are.
Given these set of
assumptions, this
is what we believe to be true.
True is that this is far more
predictable than that was.
So my theory of neuroscience,
for instance, so I'm
looking at neurotropic factors
in brain cell growth, right?
I'm looking empirically
to see, what
is the most likely explanation
for the data that I've got?
I'm looking for
understanding that
decreases dimensionality
of the space of possibility
of the search, right?
So if I can reduce it to
one variable versus two,
I have a better explanation.
That's utility.
That's useful.
I'm making a prediction.
Is it true?
Well, then we get into the
semantics of what true is.
And you could argue,
that is truth.
To be able to predict in
every single situation
is potentially true, right?
But in terms of, for instance,
what your brain is doing,
if your brain is
when the cricket
or when the male fly is trying
to mate with the female fly,
and it's trying to
predict her trajectory,
we can mathematically
model that.
Is that mathematical
model actually happening
inside that brain?
No.
It's generated behavior
that is useful, right?
Empirically.
Over the course of evolution,
learning, and development.
So science is about absolutely--
I'm not saying this is
post-modern relativism at all.
Post-modern relativism
doesn't exist.
If it did, evolution
wouldn't exist.
Some things are
better than others.
We just don't know what
they are a priori, which is
why we have empiricism, right?
What we get from that
is truth in the sense
that it's highly
predictable or more
predictable than
the previous theory.
OK?
And the way we do that-- but
that's the process of science.
That's the scientific method.
But in order to
do that, you have
to be able to ask
a good question.
And in order to
ask that question,
you have to celebrate the
possibility of being wrong,
of not knowing, right?
So my suggestion is
that what underpins
good science is a way of being
that we actually call play.
And it underpins
not just science.
Anything that is creative.
Whereas play has no intention.
It's just simply
for the sake of it.
Something like science or art
actually has an intention.
It's trying to do something.
See what I mean?
AUDIENCE: Earlier, you had a
video of people arguing about,
where was Barack Obama born?
And the way you've
defined science,
I would interpret that to
mean it doesn't actually
matter where he was born,
that where he was born
doesn't have an answer.
The only thing that matters
is what your bias is
or whether it fits your
subset of evidence.
The question of where
he was really born
doesn't really exist
anywhere in this definition,
and that's the reason why
I don't buy the definition.
That question has an answer, and
that answer is external to me,
and it's external to my biases.
And it may be true that
I have this or that bias,
but my biases have
only a limited power.
My biases do not change
where Barack Obama was born.
That fact is completely
independent of my biases.
And so I find this definition
of science to be incomplete,
because science absolutely
does care about reality.
BEAU LOTTO: Yeah.
I completely-- it doesn't
necessarily care about reality.
It cares about predictability.
The two can be very
coincident, yeah?
So I completely--
the process-- the aim
here is not to define
the process of science,
the scientific method, which of
course, I apply in my own lab.
What I'm trying to
suggest is that in order
to apply that method, you
need to have something
that comes first, right?
You have to have a
desire to ask a question.
You have to have the
willingness to doubt what
you think to be true already.
You have to be willing to doubt
your own biases to think, well,
maybe Barack Obama was
actually born here.
You have to have that if you're
going to do good science,
ie, if you're going to apply
a good scientific method.
But you could have designed
the greatest experiment,
but if you have a crap
question, who cares, right?
Because then you find
a useless answer.
I want you to come up
with a great answer,
but to do that, you have
to ask a great question.
I want you to be a
great experimentalist,
but you could be the
best experimentalist,
but you'll still be
a crap scientist.
Because you'll come
up with useless
answers if you're
not willing to ask
a question, especially a
question that challenges
your own assumptions.
And that's what
science is, is to be
able to challenge your
own assumptions of what
you think is true.
But to do that, your brain
evolved to take you away
from that place.
And one of the only places
literally in evolution
that it enables you to
challenge your own biases
is in the context of play.
That's the way of being
that enables you to do that.
And then you apply
the scientific method
of empiricism, right?
One control, one
variable, et cetera.
But having one control is like
defining an artist's painting
based on the brushstrokes
or the pigment chemistry.
The mechanism of painting is
not what defines whether or not
it was a good piece of art.
It's the view.
This is incomplete in
the sense that you then
apply a scientific method
on top of it, absolutely.
And the intention of science
is different from the intention
of art.
But the initiation, the desire
to go forward is the same,
is the argument.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And what's more, the most
successful systems in nature
are also the ones that
play into adulthood, right?
So the point is,
you have to adopt
this way of being
if you're going
to ever explore the world.
Otherwise, you'll be
stuck in your own biases
and your own
assumptions, and you'll
continue to live with the
idea that Barack Obama was
born in Africa, and not
from the States, right?
So the third point
is that in order
to be able to ask these
questions, to be in a lab,
for instance, where
questions are a good thing,
you need an ecology.
It's not good enough just to
be on your own, necessarily.
You need an environment where
asking questions, being playful
is actually a
positive thing, right?
Hence the power of
the host, the leader.
And if you ask people, what
defines good leadership,
you get all kinds
of answers, right?
But there are only three
that are associated
with the success
of any one company,
which has lead by example, admit
mistakes, and see qualities
in others.
These are the three that define
the success of any one company.
And the reason is
because they actually
create an environment of play.
The first one, lead by example,
is space that is secure.
You can't ask questions
and play outside of space
that is trusted.
This is very well known.
The second is admit mistakes.
That is space that celebrates
uncertainty, that mistakes
are OK, questions are OK.
Not answers.
All right?
Not to say that answers
are not important,
but you have to have
a good question first.
And the third is see
qualities in others.
That's the space that
celebrates diversity.
Again, three of
the parameters are
essential for a quality of play.
So we'll finish with two
examples of leadership.
Here's one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Oh, sweetie.
[INAUDIBLE] got you.
Come on.
BEAU LOTTO: Leading by
example, reassuring.
- Yeah!
- Yay!
You're almost down.
Come on!
Good girl!
[END PLAYBACK]
BEAU LOTTO: Here's the other.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEAU LOTTO: Right?
Notice he looks up
for reassurance.
[CRASH]
[END PLAYBACK]
Right?
So the question, of course, is
what kind of leader are you?
Right?
So we can just finish
with, who cares, right?
At the point when I
show you an illusion--
there is an illusion here.
The seeing yourself
is actually dark--
is the same intensity
as the see there.
Right now you're
seeing an illusion.
But as soon as you know that
you're seeing an illusion,
your brain is holding two
mutually exclusive realities
at the same time, you're
seeing one reality,
but you also know
another reality.
That's an incredibly powerful
thing for our brains,
to be able to hold two
mutually exclusive ideas
at the same time.
That is the basis
for imagination.
OK?
So this relates
ultimately to conflict.
If conflict is the only place
where we can actually learn--
and by definition
of conflict, I mean
to enter a situation that is
different from what you assume
to be true, you're in conflict.
Evolution, in that sense,
you could argue conceptually
as a conflicting process.
That's the only place where
we can actually change.
The problem is we enter conflict
in usually the same way.
If you and I are
in disagreement,
it's as if we're on different
ends of the same line.
My aim is to prove
that you're wrong
and to shift you
towards me, and your aim
is to do exactly the opposite.
In that format of conflict,
we're set up to win,
but not necessarily learn.
The question is, how does
biology deal with conflict?
Here's a riddle.
How can you move those
two dots closer together
without actually shifting the
location of the dots at all?
AUDIENCE: Enlarge the circles.
BEAU LOTTO: Enlarge
the circles, right?
You increase the space.
You increase the dimensionality
of the space, right?
In the case of genetics, it's
called extradimensional bypass,
right?
You complexify.
You complexify the system.
So while we might be at
opposite ends of the same lines,
we can actually be at
same side of a square.
It now gives you more
directions in which to move.
As you increase the
dimensionality of space,
you actually relatively become
closer and closer together,
right?
Now you create the possibility
of learning rather than
just winning.
And this is how
actually nature resolves
conflict, by increasing the
dimensionality of space.
So we'll finish with that idea.
So imagine, in order to
do that, you actually
have to enter conflict with a
question instead of an answer.
And that's the
space-- that's the way
of being that's required in
order to do good science.
You enter with a question
rather than with an answer.
OK?
So I hope that's useful.
So any questions?
AUDIENCE: OK.
This feels weird
talking on this.
I've read an article
from a mathematician that
ends up questioning reality.
And he says-- the biggest
thing that stuck out to me
was, neuroscientists are
asking the wrong question.
They shouldn't be
asking what's happening.
They should be asking, does
the gray matter even exist?
If we're always constantly
perceiving things incorrectly,
or shared perception is kind
of off, does the brain exist?
Does this chair even
exist in this reality,
or are we sharing that?
And I don't-- I'd like to hear
from a neuroscientist to tell
me a little bit about it.
BEAU LOTTO: Yeah.
So the world exists.
The physical world
exists, right?
What we perceive of that
world is not the same thing
as the world itself.
I'll give you a
very simple example
to demonstrate that
this has to be true.
Take light.
Light is a linear
spectrum from--
well, actually, it's
electromagnetic radiation,
which is a huge spectrum.
We are sensitive to a very small
window, which by definition, we
call light.
Light is part of the region
that we're sensitive to.
[INAUDIBLE]
It's a linear spectrum, right?
We perceive that as a circle.
We perceive the
short wavelengths
to be blue and the long
wavelengths to be red.
Which means that
perceptually, they
appear more similar
to each other
than they do to green,
which is in the middle.
Even though they're
physically closer to green,
they are perceptually more
similar to each other.
It's a bit like one kilo
feeling a lot like 1,000 kilos,
but very different
from 500 kilos.
So even there in our
perception of color,
we don't do an isomorphic
representation of light itself.
Our perception of
light is also color.
It has four categories, red,
green, blue, and yellow.
Spectra are uniformly,
continuously changing.
There's nothing
categorical about light.
And yet, it was
perceptually useful to see
light in terms of
four categories,
possibly because of the
four-color map problem,
cartography, where you need
four colors, a minimum of four
colors to color any map in
order to make sure two surfaces
don't actually have
the same color, two
adjoining surfaces [INAUDIBLE].
So it could be
useful that that's
why we see four
categories of color.
But it has nothing to do with
the category nature of spectra.
So spectra exists.
It's just that we don't
represent them as spectra.
We represent them in a
way that was useful, not
in the way that was accurate.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering whether it
has to do with genetics
about how people stress out
about uncertainty.
So I don't get nauseous on
the boats, and some people do.
The question is, does
it imply that I'm
more tolerant to
uncertainty, and hence,
better at doing open
questions and doing science
than these other people?
BEAU LOTTO: Yeah.
So it's a very good question.
I think it is true that
some people actually
have more tolerance for
uncertainty than others.
And it's also a really important
question why they might be so.
Now it could be genetic.
But also, if you think
about parenting--
so I have three kids.
My role, in some
sense, is to create
the certainty that enables
them to step into uncertainty.
Because you can't step into
uncertainty unless you're
stepping from someplace.
You can't play outside
of space that's trusted.
So people who often can
tolerate uncertainty,
it's because they have
something very certain
that counterbalances it.
And so a lot of education,
a lot of [INAUDIBLE],,
is about trying to create
that certainty, right?
It could be through
love, for instance,
that enables a
child, in this case,
to feel very
wanted, that enables
them to now step into and
be courageous and explore.
But often, kids
that don't have that
find it very difficult
to be in uncertainty,
because so much of
their life is uncertain.
They're actually looking for
certainly, not uncertainty.
So I don't know if it's genetic.
There seems to possibly
be a genetic component.
But there definitely is a
difference in people, right?
But the idea here is that we
can actually help people--
other people step
into uncertainty
by helping to create an ecology
that enables them to do so.
SPEAKER: Let's get a round
of applause for Beau.
[APPLAUSE]
BEAU LOTTO: Thanks
for coming in.